[Music]
bro this one's gonna go
yeah baby
this is incredible
we went from zero to a thousand bites
uh-oh this one might be a giant giant
now this is staying deep man it could be
a good one this one mate
yeah i've got this one out i've got him
out i've got him i've got most
i haven't seen it yet that's yeah it's
gonna be a big lump bro
i told you man
come on
that's a dinosaur
we're gonna need a bigger voice dude
i'm mike iaconelli my friends and i grew
up fishing the mean streams and rivers
of philadelphia
[Music]
i'm a professional angler
with a screaming passion
for city fishing
all it takes is a little skill and a
local
to show you where the fish are biting
london is one of the world's great
capital cities and one of the oldest so
i better have a spot of tea
it's got history out the wazoo there are
famous landmarks everywhere
and flowing through the heart of london
is a mighty river
this is the thames river it's 215 miles
long and flows into the north sea
[Music]
it's the longest river in southern
england
julius caesar crossed the thames in 54
bc
and a hundred years later the romans
invaded
england they built a port called
londinium and feasted on fish from the
river
over the next 2 000 years their
settlement grew into one of the world's
great cities the greater london area has
almost 10 million people and you know
what else is lurking in london town a
veritable king's ransom of fish where
can i catch an english pike don't worry
go away
people have been fishing in the thames
since the bronze age
that's over 4 000 years ago
why because there are over a hundred
species of fish living in it
[Music]
i've picked three iconic species from my
london bucket list
my number one target one of the world's
most awesome freshwater predators
the pike is like a freshwater barracuda
with a huge mouth full of razor sharp
teeth and a long lean powerful body
the pike is so badass it was named after
a medieval weapon
in the middle ages soldiers used long
spears called pikes to fight off cavalry
because of its shape the fish was named
after these deadly weapons
the lord mayor of london still has a
ceremonial bodyguard armed with pikes
i'm really excited about trying to land
one of these beasts in the middle of one
of the world's great cities
my first time here i've always wanted to
visit this part of the world
i'm meeting a guy who calls himself the
piscatorial prince of the thames
cascatorio means devoted to fishing
calling yourself fishing royalty is
pretty bold
let's see if he can deliver
work
hi dang how you doing can i come up
aboard absolutely slip board
let's go boys
warwick has caught some huge pike right
where he moars his boat so we don't have
to go far out to our first fishing spot
[Music]
he's been fishing the thames for 15
years so i'm in good hands
yeah the reason why i like this area uh
is you have a lot of people coming down
here and feeding all the swans uh
they're all eating the bread that people
are throwing in the little particles are
falling down uh smaller fish are coming
in for that obviously you'll find in the
predatory fish sitting behind them right
a little circle light theory going on
there it all starts with brent
we're trying large artificial wars as
our first plan of attack rap
they're huge but pike have got huge
mouths
these powerful predators will hunt
almost any other living creature in and
on the river including other pike and
even birds
put that one on and as we come up this
wall here just put the rod out to the
side yeah i'll keep you really close to
the boat just keep it out next to the
boat hopefully we'll we'll
pick something up there cheeky little
one there quickly
nice vibration on that thing yeah
i've come a long way to try to capture
this thing man i i don't want to go back
to the states without catching one
but it's not going to be easy
it's the middle of winter and the thames
is running really cold
if i'm going to tempt a pike in the
biting i'm going to have to switch
things up time to make some changes here
folks
i don't know i'm i'm getting desperate
man
you know what i'm saying a little bit of
scent
it uh
basically imitates the smell of of bait
fish
it's red color looks like blood
put a little bit of that on the head of
the bait make it look injured give it
some scent trying to peel to every
element now
because this is tough
winter time in london this ain't easy
just a few decades ago it would have
been a lot harder to catch a pike here
because the thames was officially dead
[Music]
200 years of industry dumping toxins
poisoned the river
bombing during world war ii damaged
sewer systems so that was leaking into
the river too
news reports from the 1950s describe the
thames as a vast foul-smelling drain
but decades of restoration have brought
the river back to life
now the fish are back
just not on my hook
it's time to go for a cruise upriver
we're heading to a royal playground
man look at that thing
hampton court palace
wow
super super impressive look at that
thing
a lot of history there
in the 16th century hampton court was
supersized by one of england's most
infamous kings
[Music]
henry viii is best known for his six
wives and many mistresses
hampton court became his pleasure palace
where he whined and dined them
but most people don't realize that king
henry viii was one of the first monarchs
to protect britain's river fisheries
[Music]
he made walls preventing the killing or
poaching of young eels and salmon and in
four strict fishing seasons almost 500
years ago
nice one henry
maybe you weren't all bad
[Music]
warwick has found a new spot just up
from hampton court palace next to one of
the thames famous weirs
weirs control the amount of water that
flows down the river
after two days of rain the gates are
wide open and the current is pumping
there's a big hole that comes over here
and then it comes out of the hole and
then the hole's about sort of about 15
to 20 feet deep but then it comes up to
a plateau at the back here it goes about
three feet you can you can actually walk
across wow and so where we find the hole
we'll fish along the edges of that hole
that's where we're gonna find some fish
pike are ambush predators so they'll be
sitting just under the drop off waiting
for something to swim above them
you've got a little bit of calm water
over here on the left
you've got a calm water on the right
you've got a steady flow in the middle
man this is a good looking spot the
other thing is honestly you get up here
and you can
you can almost smell it i don't know if
it's if it's the smell of bait but
actually smells fishy up here to me
we'll try up around the corner here
first then we'll work our way back down
again
ask where we're gonna catch one
you know pike are pretty vicious
even in cold water scenario they're a
little more slow they're a little more
lethargic
but it's still a vicious predator
most of the strikes that we're going to
get whether it's on live bait or
artificials are going to be vicious it's
gonna be quick and strong
and it's gonna be a heck of a fight
pike belonged to an ancient family of
fish that were around at the time of the
dinosaurs
and they still look prehistoric
that one
broke me off
[Music]
oh man fish all day and you finally get
that bite i'm i'm actually my legs are
still shaking
luckily it doesn't take long until i'm
back in
business bottom again
big one
big one
bottom again
big one
[Music]
i'm in london fishing on the famous
river thames
something just hit my lure hard
and it might be my top bucketless fish
the pike
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
look at that thing that's the northern
pike
look how long
and lean these fish are
this thing is a vicious predator look
how far down this bait is
look at that
that's a six inch bait
and that fish sucked it in look at that
pike have got huge mouths full of
razor-sharp teeth
but they don't always need them
they swallow their prey whole
ah look look look look look that shows
you how sharp the teeth are look at that
oh
had my glove it's one of the fastest
predators in fresh water i really want
to take it to the pub
and trade it in for a pint of beer
but i think i'm just going to let it go
instead
we came at the absolute worst time
to london
to catch these fish winter time after a
heavy rain we get up here and i break
one off and i just tied another bait on
the same bait and threw back and caught
one
man that's what fishing's all about it's
about the ups and downs it's about
failing
but working through the failure
to catch one and that's what it's all
about man absolutely
thank you well done fellas thank you
thank you that's what there's a cu buzz
like this let's go catch another one
let's go back to that corner man
it's funny how fishing works after
hardly any bites all day i'm now getting
hit by pike every time i put my line
back in the water
this one strikes so hard it snaps the
end of my rod
[Music]
oh yeah baby
it doesn't take long to hook pike number
three these things are coming from
everywhere
[Laughter]
i'm mike
they call me ike
and this is my pike
[Music]
thank you pleasure palace
thank you henry viii
and thank you piscatorial prince of the
thames i sure picked the right guide
warwick has made sure i've caught my
bucket list pike in style
but this day isn't over yet
yeah baby
this is incredible
this fish feels a lot bigger than the
first three
yeah well it calls giant pike over 20
pounds crocodiles and this could be one
pull it back
this one might be a toad man
i haven't seen it yet that's yeah it's
going to be a big lump bro my mind
here we go what's up
[Music]
this is a crocodile we're gonna need a
bigger vintage it's a dinosaur
wow look at that
now that's what you call a fish look at
that
look at that thing
now that is a world-class pike so
gorgeous look at that thing
and it feeds with all its senses
pike used their lateral lines to pick up
vibrations in the water and their giant
eyes give them good vision
and finally on the top of their heads
are large nostrils
and if you look on his bottom gill plate
you're going to see leeches
and this is really a great indication
of what these fish are doing in cold
water
they're laying on the bottom they're
almost resting on the bottom to conserve
energy
under these cold dirty water conditions
unbelievable let's weight that thing
it's got to be over 20. uh just over 21
pounds 21 and a quarter pounds 2100
quarter pounds you just joined the
crocodile club
yeah baby
yeah 21 and a quarter pounds
as i'm releasing my crocodile it gives
me a last little present
a reminder of how sharp its teeth are i
bleed my own blood for that fish split
me wide open it's gonna keep bleeding
it's gonna continue to bleed
that fish could hurt me
but i definitely am not going to hurt
that fish
what a start to my london fishing trip
four pike on the first day including a
giant
take that one off the bucket list yeah
dude proud of you
i think i'm buzzing as much as you are
that's unbelievable
[Music]
day two of my london fishing expedition
now that i fished the legendary river
thames it's time for london's other
waterways
today i'm checking out the famous river
wandel
the wandel is short and sharp it's about
11 miles long and flows through
southwest london into the temps
the water is swift and clear and it's
got a clean gravel bottom
perfect habitat for my next bucket list
fish
the legendary barbel
i'm meeting up with a keen urban
fisherman and london native
hopefully his local knowledge will land
me a barbel
matthew hey mike how you doing what's up
nice to meet you hey thanks for meeting
me that's the cool man fingers crossed
we're going to catch a bubble okay yeah
is just marvel or what else is in this
thing uh well does bauble just chop a
nails they're the ones we're gonna
target well i'm excited to catch a
barbel i've never caught one it's gonna
be a new species on my bucket list yeah
you can take that one off hopefully
gotta catch this thing but dude what
part of town is this oh this is
wimbledon wimbledon like the tennis yeah
that's why that's what's cool it's good
so if we don't catch anything you know
what's happening that's a good backup
plan yeah we're gonna go over game won't
we
so let's have a little look out a lot of
current
yeah it's a fair there's a fair bit
pretty clear it's pretty clear but it's
a bit of a bit of color like we're
talking about the rain earlier on yeah
yeah
normally in the in the summer this is
gin clear
barb will prefer current and a gravel
bottom
they feel around on the riverbed with
their sensitive barbels hunting for
insects snails and worms
and because they're adapted to living in
strong current they're powerful swimmers
that's why barbel are prized by english
anglers for their fighting qualities
in fact barbal are often called the
prince of the river
i can't wait to have a crack at catching
british fish royalty how are we catching
them we using lures or bait no we're
gonna use bait bait yeah what kind of
bait um spam do you know what spam is
like like the the meat the meat spam
yeah like they used to eat in the walk
there was nothing else that's crazy it's
good it's nice have you ever tried it
i've never had it i'll treat you trying
a little bit if the barbell are going to
eat it i want to eat it lucky i'm not
using worms then isn't it
[Laughter]
i can't believe we're trying to catch
the prince of the river with plain old
spam
oh well matt's the expert
but first we've got to do some ground
work
all right so this is what you're going
to use to bait the holes we'll put a
little bit of this in once we got to the
end we're going to double back on
ourselves and fish on those gadgets we
use this device called the bait dropper
and what it is is you put that you put
whatever mixture you want inside it yeah
close it up and it's got a little hook
on the top right okay you tied it onto
the end of your line yeah and cast it
out and when it hits the bottom
it will open up
it's amazing that's tricky it's good
this is fishing's all about tricky isn't
it this is james bond stuff going on
right here you might be the james bond
of a viral figure that's the best
comment i've ever had
[Music]
i love this bait dropper gadget it's a
great way to chum a bunch of fishing
holes quickly
[Music]
and we're going to need every advantage
we can get to hook a barbel
not only is it winter
we're going to be fishing at night
this might be my biggest london
challenge yet
it's a freezing cold london night
we've already baited up a bunch of spots
on the river wandel
but my guide matt had to go to work and
by the time he comes back
it's pitch black
all right i'm ready to finally get the
fishing enough of the baiting
i want my next bucket list fish the
barbel real bad
stood on there isn't it no
come off i had them all for a fraction
second that wasn't a barbell
it's a waiting game it's it's patience
it's letting the bait sit and soak
and letting the smell
and scent of that spam go downstream
little trick piece of equipment for
fishing at night
is we're actually using
a glow tip
and for fishing in these dark conditions
that really helps you
identify a bite
[Music]
temperatures are dropping and it's
getting late
but a true fisherman never gives up
matt and i both had a few bites
so there's definitely something in there
that likes the taste of spam
look at this thing what a weird species
this is look at him twisting look at him
just in my hand trying to twist around
look
super super slimy
man if this thing was on the bank look
at it you'd think it was a snake look at
it look at it same movements
as a snake
this is not a barbel
but this is a really strange looking
weird creature
that has a big connection
to the city of london
the european eel was once abundant but
it's now considered critically
endangered
eels are nocturnal so they like to hide
out during the day
and come out at night to hunt
[Music]
they are predators
and scavengers
but also pray for lots of other species
and that includes us
the ancient romans caught and ate eels
from the thames
but it wasn't until london grew to
become a huge industrial city
that the eel became part of its culture
eels were cheap and nutritious so they
became food of the working class
jellied eel and eel pie fed generations
of londoners and became iconic street
food
the eel
provided a food source
when things were bad
and right now they're protected
so we're allowed to catch these things
but you can't keep them we've got to put
that fish back you know it's not a
barbel
but no trip to london would be complete
without catching an eel
thank you
mr eel you weird-looking creature for
biting my spam
go back home
we're gonna keep moving we're running
and gunning until we catch a barbel
[Music]
it's getting real late
matt has got one more spot to try
this is cool though you know
we're fishing at night in the city of
london
and you've got the noises uh the
factories
i mean giant factory right here next to
us machinery equipment
it's such a weird diverse mix
oh wait wait wait
wait
wait
i'm getting a lot of small bites but i
don't think they're barble
if its reputation is true a barbel
should hit my bait hard when it strikes
so it's probably just more eels sniffing
around it's real late and real dark and
real cold
time to pull the plug for tonight
mr barbel if you're gonna do it do it
now we're jetting it's cold
i'm tired i'm hungry
i need a beer
should we wrap it up then probably
should huh
can i take that spam back with me and
have it for dinner of course you can i
hate to give up tonight but sometimes in
fishing you gotta just cut your losses
and call it water under the bridge
tonight's a done deal but tomorrow is a
new day
it's a new day in london and another
chance to catch a bucket list fish
but first i'm taking the london
underground rail system to fish hq the
city's fish market super cold outside
within the train it's kind of warm
here we are buildings gate market one of
the most iconic fish markets in the
entire world
can't wait to get my eyes on a lot of
different fish right here in london
england
billings gate market sits on the isle of
dogs
nobody seems to know why it's called
that
but we do know that the bodies of
executed prisoners used to be hung along
the shore here
in cages
in the 19th century the billings gate
fish market was the largest in the world
and even today it's one of the most
iconic
any day you can find up to 150 different
types of fish for sale here
coming from all around the world
[Music]
london even imports its eels now these
slimy beauties come from holland
holy eel
getting to see fish from all over the
world
pretty amazing the number of different
species i'm laying my eyes on sea bass
squid flounder salmon
a lot of saltwater species
where's the freshwater fish i've still
got two of my london bucket list fish to
catch
the barbel
and the european perch
i'm hoping to get some good intel on
them here at the market but where are
they
do you have any idea where i could find
perch or barbell alive in the water you
won't get it not this time of year now
in the winter in london very difficult
to fish
because at the end of the day most of
the fish now go further away
so what you need is the summer when the
fish are here right the time to go
fishing so in the winter they're cold
and they migrate to the warm weather
they move away is there anything alive
swimming in tents
yeah mostly yeah a seal nice seal out
there seal yeah you'll see him outside
wow look at that it's a she
and what's her name i think sammy you
could have sent me the sale sammy the
seal okay hi girl
how you doing sammy the seal has been
showing up here for a decade eating
scraps of fish that are thrown to her
she's a local celebrity who has been
returned to the wild several times but
it's never long before she shows up here
again do you have any idea where i can
catch a perch and a barbell
just point me in the direction
does that mean there's none here
there are more than 700 seals living at
the mouth of the thames
for a river that was biologically dead
in the 1950s having that many marine
mammals is fantastic progress
they wouldn't live here if there wasn't
plenty of food and that's good news
because seals are keen fishermen just
like me sammy here sammy send me
something
all right well you take it easy i've got
a job to do
see you later
[Music]
nice to make sammy the seals
acquaintance
but i need to get back to fishing
i've arranged to meet matthew one more
time
and try to catch my bucket list barbell
but this time we've got daylight on our
side
it'll be easy for us to see the fish but
also easier for them to see us
barble have good eyesight it could be
harder to catch them in the day than at
night
[Music]
hey my mind matt
here we're ready thanks for meeting me
again early bird catches the barbie
that's right another day no but i i'm
not going back to the states unless i
catch one of these
in summer barb will hang out in the
current and feed
but in winter they lay low in the deeper
pools to conserve energy
we're gonna have to be patient and stake
out one of these pools
this is the one that's truly unique for
me dude i've never caught a barbel you
can't find him in the states
matt has got a new rig for us to try out
this is this is the paste
so that's
it looks like a dog poo yeah
so that's the paste
oh yeah so uh pinch off a decent sized
ball
um
push the spare into the middle and
literally
literally mold it mold it around just
encapsulate that yeah
wow i see i get it
so
there it goes new rig today for barbell
this paste is actually going to
dissipate it's going to dissolve
and all that scent material is going to
start flowing downstream
that's going to attract those barbells
those barbells are going to smell that
scent and he's going to come behind it
and
suck it in and when he does
there you go he's hooked
it's a cool rig
we know they're in there
and the longer our bait ball dissolves
the longer the scent trail in the water
mmm this scared me
but i saw a bit of a bite there
come on barbell
eat
big
[Music]
i'm a patient man
but even i'm starting to wonder if this
is gonna happen
maybe it's just too cold for the barbel
to take the bait
it's looking like my london bucket list
might just kick the bucket
[Music]
i'm in london fishing the river wandel
it's day two of the hunt for my next
bucket list fish the barbel
and time is running out fast
we're fishing for a
barbel
his brain is about the size of a pea
and somehow
can't outsmart this thing
[Music]
the wandel has been famous for its
fishing for centuries but that swift
current meant it was also perfect for
powering mills
during the 19th century there were as
many as a hundred water wheels in about
11 miles of river the wandel was
described as the hardest worked river
for its size in the world
all that industry polluted the river but
lately a big effort has gone into
cleaning it up
it's once again one of the best places
in london to catch the prince of the
river
matt suggests one more spot
a deeper pool that we got a few bites in
last night
this is my last chance at catching a
barbel
[Music]
got one
there's one it's good
[Music]
massive
true to its reputation the prince of the
river is putting up a hell of a fight
don't go in don't do it
it's almost dragging me in the fish fish
i got it you okay let's just take a
drink okay slowly slowly
this is only this is only eight pound
test i'm praying that my light rig will
handle this feisty fish if i lost it now
i think my head would explode look at
this look at the pool on this thing
i'm afraid i keep i'm scared just gonna
get me on that stump over there
stay on there stay on there stay on
there please stay on there
this is a giant man
easy easy come on slowly slowly easy
enough
easy get up get up
yeah
yeah
look at this beast
finally
this
is the fish i came
to london england for
that is the barbel
look at that beautiful
creature look at the barbels
on the front of the mouth
barbel are specialist bottom feeders
their belly is flattened to hug the
riverbed
their eyes are high on the side of their
head and their small mouth scoops up
food off the bottom
and those distinctive barbels detect any
small creature living in the gravel
these things can get massive
britain's largest barbel weighed over 20
pounds
she was known as the big lady
and unfortunately she was eaten by an
otter
this thing's special because i can't get
this at home
i traveled all this way
to put my hands on one and i finally did
barbel
thank you for one of the best fights of
my life and now out of respect
i've got to let you go
prince of the river
thank you
and look look look look
it's been tough but all that hard work
and hypothermia have been worth it
i now have two of my three bucket list
fish and with that win there's only one
thing to do
celebrate in traditional london
fisherman style matt to the pub
[Music]
london's public houses or pubs are a
huge part of the city's history
there are thousands of them and many are
beside waterways
for centuries happy fishermen have
visited london pubs to toast their
success what was harder the weight for
the barbel or the weight for the pipe
for the punch
it was way harder chairs
to a good session to a barbell you're
fishing in london cheers
two down
and one london bucketless fish to go
man i got to be honest with you this has
been one of the weirdest strangest
fishing trips i've ever had
we're in london in middle winter it's
freezing cold challenging fishing but
the funny thing is i caught my top fish
the pike pretty easily
in fact i got four of them
the barbell was much harder but in the
end i caught a beautiful one
now all that's left to do is complete
the set and catch a european perch and
today is gonna be my last opportunity to
do it
european perch are sentimental favorites
of many british anglers it's often the
first fish they've ever caught when they
were kids
perch are not the biggest fish around
but they have a reputation for being
bold predators
i'm meeting two of the best street
fishermen in all of london alan and
alfie
hopefully they're going to lead me to my
last bucket list fish
i'm meeting the guys in east london
where the river lee flows into the temps
this area is a maze of waterways full of
good fish habitat
guys mike how you doing so great to
finally meet you welcome to london alan
yeah great to meet you in person
nice to meet you mike
good to see you how's the fishing the
fishing i stayed here all night and it
was very slow but five minutes before
you arrived i've only gone and caught a
carp you caught a car car we can't
believe it it's impossible
it's never impossible if you try oh hell
yeah
yeah
yeah
so he's a very wild fish um he could
have been living in here for a
big one an incredible long time he could
be 40 years old this one here has been
living in this pretty harsh environment
for a long time yeah now how much does
this fish weigh yeah he's an upper
double getting on for 20 pounds
beautiful fish
common carp are native to eastern europe
and asia
but humans have spread them all over the
world
gorgeous fish yeah they first appeared
in this country many many years ago and
they were brought over by the monks as a
source of food right um they were put
into the monasteries the monks ate them
carp were introduced into the united
states for food too but since the 1870s
they've become a pest
so cool man let's get a purse yeah so
talk to me about baits for perch i
noticed you've got lure rods which is
awesome that's
a really good way of catching them i
tend to like to use worms yeah uh red
worms dendrobinas lob worms yeah and you
love your life basically live baits yeah
something a little bit more active
naturally in in the colder weather you
know gotcha
alfie's right when fish are cold they
really don't want to eat so one trick
you can use is to excite them
my lures are designed to do that but
wiggling live bait will too
how much longer have you got today's my
last day no way
we need to capture this thing yeah try
and make this happen i gotta get one
come on let's
go wow look at them pistons on that
thing
oh
proper hydraulics
the river lee was once a natural
waterway that flowed into the thames and
has been celebrated for its fishing for
centuries
today at the london end it's heavily
modified and channelized
but there are still fish in there i can
smell them
rafi i think there's a good chance here
oh what's that
maybe snagged off on something there
scared me i thought you had one already
yeah so did i
you're just feeling for vibrations yeah
i've been here for more than an hour now
and not a nibble
surely they can't be this hard to catch
man
we've got deep water
we've got plenty of cover sea walls
rocks
so we're trying to cover a little bit of
water in this area and see if we can get
a bite
with the day ticking away pressure's
mounting
[Music]
i can't just stay in one spot we've got
to keep moving
whoa
this is title title yeah
super low hey there's a nice hatchet
yeah you could see them if they were
here this is uh it's a bit shallow yeah
mark we'll just show you there's a canal
the other side it's worth checking it's
just 100 yards that way let's peep it
this just keeps getting harder
on top of everything else it's low tide
which means a lot of places are way too
shallow to fish
we need to find some fishable water and
soon
it's like they're not even here you know
they are
it's like they're
[Music]
ghosts excuse me do you know where any
perch are at perch
which way
we've had two hours here
not a people life
oh boy
we've got one last throw of the dice
allen and alfie lead me to the famous
canary wharf
heart of london's financial district
and home of some of the tallest
buildings in europe
in the 1800s this was one of the busiest
docks in the world
the boat traffic is long gone but it's
still got deep water and hopefully a few
perch
we're really in the final quarter here
we've got about an hour left of light
barb will find their food using smell
and touch so they can feed at night
but perch are visual predators when it
gets too dark they stop biting
the clock is ticking
and it's a really big clock
this is my last chance i i feel the
pressure man and i have to try to catch
this european perch
unfortunately i've got to get back to
the states i've got a big world
championship event next week
and i can't budget another hour
this is my last chance
i'm gonna throw it all at them
work hard the last hour one stinking
perch man
[Music]
man
i am tired
i'm hungry i'm disappointed i'm
depressed
i could not
capture
a european perch man i i i hate to fail
i hate to lose but
london got me
london got me this week
[Music]
what do you think guys
we worked hard we did everything we
could do that's fishing that's fishing i
don't know how you feel but it just
makes me want to come back again and and
catch one of these but
maybe one day well the great thing in
failure is you want to come back and
succeed so if i come back to london will
you guys take me perch fishing again 100
100
and maybe a little cart fishing too for
sure appreciate you guys taking me nice
to meet you i had a blast
thank you mike you guys take it easy
we'll see you catch you later take it
easy london got me
at this point the only thing i know to
do is to wave the flag
[Music]
you got me london
but i'll be back
[Music]
you